حي رجال محمد طير صور وانشر بدنا نشوف صور
وانشر بدنا
[تصفيق]
نشوف اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم المدع العام السويسري
يكشف عن تقديم شكاوى جرئيه ضد الرئيس
الاسرائيلي اسحاق هرتسوغ خلال مشاركته في
منتدى دافوس ويقول للجزيره انه يتواصل مع
الخارجيه السويسريه وسيتم اصدار بيان بشان
الخطوه التاليه بعد النظر في الشكاوى في
حين خرجت مظاهرات في اليمن والاردن تضامنا
مع الشعب الفلسطيني وتنديدا بالمجازر التي
يرتكبها الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وتجدون
المزيد من اخبار حرب غزه في رابط بالتعليق
الاول حلف شمال الاطلس النيتو يعلن انه
سيبدا الاسبوع القادم اكبر تدريب عسكري له
منذ الحرب البارده وسيشارك فيه 90 الف
عسكري على مدى اشهر ويهدف الى ردع روسيا
ابتداء من اوا فبراير بحسب وكاله الانباء
الالمانيه البرلمان الالماني يوافق على
سلسله اجراءات من شانها تجديد سياسه
الهجره في البلاد وتسهيل ترحيل اللاجئين
ورئيس الوزراء البريطاني يدعو مجلس
اللوردات لاقرار مشروع القانون المثير
للجدل الذي طرحه حول الهجره والذي ينص على
ترحيل المهاجرين الوافدين بصوره غير
قانونيه الى
رواندا تركيا تدخل نادي الدول الزائره
لمحطه الفضاء الدوليه وذلك بارسال رائد
الفضاء البر جازر افجي في اول رحله ماهوله
لبلاده الى الفضاء وسط احتفاء واسع في
تركيا وانطلق رئد الفضاء التركي في رحله
مع ثلاثه رواد اوروبيين ضمن احدث بعثه
تجاريه لشركه اكسيوم سبيس الناشئه في
تكساس الى
اللقاء